your name i feel always pops up when
somebody leaves housewives it's always
like kimura should go on that [ __ ] i
know
they definitely have asked me
inside of me was some drag queen
that had to get out of there that's a
hard question it's not a question i've
never been asked
i'm gonna hang up on you i said that oh
my gosh
no kamora 2020 has not been many
people's year
but i feel like some good stuff happened
for you this year you adopted
a child and you launched baby fat beauty
why was now the time to re-enter the
beauty space it just seemed like a great
time
and i feel like only today i can say
that we
are what we set out to be 20 something
years ago
which is a heritage brand which is a
legacy brand
we wanted something that would stay
around and retro is a big
um do i stay quiet on the set you can
say quiet on the set
why on the set is that you ace
no one's here listen to me they don't
care see why i say it's not like dynasty
or those
live shows we're not that glamorous
hello they don't care and now that i
said something they're scared they're
not gonna answer
we're gonna go back so it's about um i
think a big point of this is retro
this working from home life is not easy
okay they got it so a big point of this
we're talking about is this concept of
retro so it's about retrograde
and we've been putting it together
little by little
and a big ask for a lot of people
is is beauty and so we thought of
individual pieces just
everything that's cute and a little
zipper pvc pouch with the cat on it
and everybody loves it and it thinks
that people are now doing more in terms
of like staying at home and being
on the zoom and working from home and so
your beauty is not like you're not gonna
obviously this is the whole thing but
you could do your lip gloss your little
shimmer
you could put something you know people
are naked from the waist out right
i'm not uh no but i love it we got proof
we got pants on
uh but it is kind of touch up the top
honey give it a little shimmer a little
gloss
a little goes a long way it's always
been a babe like my baby and i think
that it's always been a brand that's so
closely connected with myself my family
my kids and
i think that's how people remember us
walking down the runway and the girls
were little and now they're big and
can do their own runway but you know
it's like a family a family we've built
right together it's like i didn't have
brook shields in my jeans but i had ming
and aoki on that runway like you know
it's been 30 years since your first et
interview at home in st
louis was it yes november 1990
was when we came there and followed you
in a day in the life
do you want fame necessarily
um that's a hard question that's a
question i've never been asked
i think it's something that again you
have to be pretty stable for because
everyone says yes i want it
and then when it hits you you don't know
what to do with it and you get
caught up in it and you get confused so
i think
because i have good good family and good
friends
i can say yes i want it and it won't hit
me and knock me down
but some people i think do get caught up
and it totally knocks them over
but as far as i'm concerned right now i
mean it's it's fine
if you can live your wildest dreams
where would you like to see yourself
singing
five years by the time you're 20.
my wildest dream gosh i'd love to uh
there's it's just so many different
things if i was if it were
in in fashion you know i could be i
could be the top model and be on every
magazine cover but then if it were
just as far as my life is concerned well
not when i'm 20
but i always you know as far as
government there's a lot of things i'd
like to see done
in america that i think we could we
could make better with our with our
society
so when i'm 20 years old i think i'm
just going to be getting started
seeing that now um
what do you what do you think of 15 year
olds kimura i think then i was
i felt like the black sheep of my family
and kind of st
louis and i know inside i was so much
more fabulous than that
so i just had to like roll with the
punches literally right because i got my
butt handed to me on a regular basis
because these crazy girls or whatever
and so i think it's a lot of the same
concepts that we're working to make it a
better
place and i never even saw that i'm
proud to look all these years later i
have
five kids i'm a mother of five five kids
three husbands
lots of candy lots of dogs
lots of friends lots of cats right like
come on that's crazy
is there anything you would tell that
girl that 15 year old
girl other than you can let the
fabulosity out a little sooner
well let out there was none of that in
there let it out and those people are
picking on you they're trolls and they
are
ugly and they are ugly inside and out
girl listen to me
i always thought it then but now i know
for sure they're mean and so i would
tell her yeah hold her head up because
you're on to something
and other people who are really mean and
judge you for whatever your background
how you look your orientation whatever
the hell
they're losers it's the same thing i've
only just gotten more and more
confident and a little braver to be able
to say that right
a little older but it's the same message
for sure i know that for a fact they're
evil trolls
i hope they watch this well it's kind of
it's it's kind of wild to know how far
we've come since then and how
things have changed but not as much as
maybe we would want them to change
i thought it was so interesting the
through line of talking about wanting to
be politically active then at 15 and
then now i know where you are where
you're very politically active talk to
me about
um collaborating with stacey abrams fair
fight
we did team up with them and a portion
of the proceeds everything that we make
or sold
um went back to them and it was really
about if you want
to make a change then you have to take
advantage of
lots of these laws and rights
rights that we have right as voters as
women voters
people of color like come on use it use
it or lose it
i think that's really the underlying
message is about literacy
uh yeah education awareness um to kind
of make sure that those things don't
continue
happening i want to talk through some
other things you said in that first
interview that you were opinionated even
then that there were little moments of
the more we know are coming out back
then i have the rules of a grade school
child i'm treated so unfair
i'm going to tell you now let it all out
in the open i just got a curfew
of 12 o'clock 12 can you imagine what
can you do until 12.
it would be crazy to me that like i'd go
all over the world but i wouldn't have a
curfew when i come home and
midnight is my curfew i wasn't doing
anything crazy anyway
no you seemed like a a rule a bit of a
rule follower
and i'm a homebody my kids are kind of
too i try to keep it pretty
straight sometimes
also in the interview you said you
preferred mcdonald's to any of the
food in any of the places that you had
to travel to french food is
something that i'm really not interested
in right now and mcdonald's they have a
lot of
burger places um even french ones but
definitely mcdonald's is like home for
me and that's where i live as bad as it
sounds for a model to eat mcdonald's i
live off of mcdonald's i love it there
it's the greatest thing that is
horrendous but i grew up in the midwest
so everything was like fast food
now we're nothing like that all of our
kids even wolves he
just turned five in april and you know
yeah they
eat all the french cuisine now they're
trying lots of new things they may be
vegan sometimes
they may be kosher sometimes
anything like we're trying different you
know things and
to be healthy and to be you know the
evolution
definitely not the mcdonald's yeah and
then the other thing you said that stuck
out to me
i want to always stay in saint louis
because st louis is my home
and i've never been i've never been
anywhere other than st louis i'm gonna
hang up on you
i said that oh my gosh no i my whole
life
is telling everyone to get out of st
louis only because
inside of me was some drag queen
that had to get out of there like
there's no way that i could stay in st
louis missouri i was six feet tall i'm
six foot four in heels if there's any
little platform i'm six five or six six
i don't think i could have stayed in st
louis but you can go back it's like any
small town you can't just stay tipping
cows forever dorothy
from kansas but kansas and those red
glittery shoes
are like i don't know christian
louboutin we made it all the way girls
okay
that little pumpkin coach we are on the
other side of the rainbow now hello
it has been seven years since your last
reality show ended
do you want to go back to reality tv at
all do you miss it at all
um no it was fun but it was a little
crazy
the excitement of the world cannot be
like only how downtrodden and
your all of your downfall that can't be
i wanted to inspire people i wanted to
educate them in terms of like fashion
and business and how to be a go-getter
and how to
have um something from nothing
and this whole spirit of entrepreneur
ship
and vision and and those things so i did
it it was very tough my kids grew up
for you know a long time in front of the
camera but it was it was hard and then
it went
reality tv just kind of like everything
crazy came in where it's like just an
invasion of your life and everything
kind of morphs one into the next so
now we're somewhere in there and lots of
people have come up to me for projects
you know to do things now and you know i
don't know
your name i feel always pops up when
somebody leaves housewives it's always
like kimura should go on that [ __ ] i
know
i don't know why can i do a cameo
i know andy that's all his stuff right
i'm not sure how that would be because
are they gonna be in my house there's
levels of casting
where you can do like friend of where
you're just there for like the girl
scenes but they're never in your
house oh i'm gonna do that i can do that
and i like
a lot of them i know a lot of them and
uh
you know i don't i'm not into all that
you know that i'm not into all that
fighting and crazy drama
i mean i can be but i don't want to be
but so they've so the you know the blogs
always
speculate but they've never actually
approached you about this
no oh i'm surprised by that i see it in
social media no no they probably have
i take that back no no i take that back
they definitely have asked me
every couple years in between seasons or
in between people they definitely have
asked me
but i've never been in like real talk
all right so if they were to come to you
you might entertain it
but you have never had a full
conversation about it well i've never
had any conversation they have called my
office
i always say no i do hear about it going
on i never really know
i like probably love most of the girls
i'm sure there's a few that you could
slip through that i don't but you know i
like a lot of the girls it was because
garcelle was on there right mm-hmm
did she get in trouble though see i
don't know what they do on tv she's
no she wasn't in trouble denise richards
got in trouble this is garcelle's second
season that she's filming right now and
that's usually the tricky one
oh okay so anything going on i'm going
to defer to you
and if anybody's watching this and they
and we want to talk they should
i'm going to also send them to you okay
great i will
coordinate it all through here for you
we'll be like
the first season's okay the second
season you better watch right yeah
yeah no i gave that warning to garcelle
she's so level-headed though
i just love her and i i feel like we
have a lot of similarities in our life
things that we've gone through she's
headed like me
i'm a hot head so that night i wrote an
email to
friends and colleagues at mike's work
and the subject
was what does tiger woods jesse james
and mike nylon have in common
and that emailed got leaked to the press
email all girl
yes eamonn i love her she's
my idol
that was my first question i was like is
this the energy you're bringing to the
show garcelle is it an
apply all situation might need to be and
she said
only let people rock all over you so
much and then you feel like sometimes
the need to strike back
you're not just going to lay down and
take every damn thing there comes a time
when
we can't take it anymore that doesn't
mean afterwards that we can't be friends
or that doesn't act
you know that we have to agree to
disagree probably means you're gonna get
your ass
i'm always ten i'm violent huh i'm gonna
stop that who knows
we may you may start getting calls okay
you're the agent on record
i am uh happy to take them happy to have
conversations
you know andy i don't know if i'm going
to call you call me hey we'll see
we'll laugh about the things they're
going to talk to us about we'll see
we'll be like no one can come over here
except for garcia all right
in another interview you recently did
you poked fun at how many times you've
been married said you'll be married two
more times before you die what's going
on are you single right now
no comment
okay i am just me
you are kimura right now okay in a crazy
time that i will say that and everybody
knows that and it's been a crazy year
and
and for me personally it's been a crazy
couple of years
and everybody in the world that knows
how to read between the lines are going
to be between lines and then underneath
they're going to be typing and they're
going to say i knew
and i told you this and i'm just trying
to avoid all that and keep my head down
and mind my business
but it's a very tricky time out there
for a lot of reasons we'll say
and i'm always cracking jokes and
inappropriate jokes and lots of stuff
and they're always loaded with truth
and innuendo honey but that's just me
and you have to like dig through it to
understand
but offline we could have another talk
about the status of affairs
okay i'm open to that conversation let's
get in the dms and hash it out
this year like i said has been a year of
change year of complications
learnings what is something that brought
you joy though in 2020
um well i have my son gary
gary lee and and he's been here actually
yeah for like a year
so he right before um the pandemic
um he came to permanently live with us
and he
is an amazing young man a little boy
you probably got to spend a lot more
time with him than you were expecting
because of everything so
that's a big one i love having all the
kids home
and having said that the 18 and the 19
the 20 year olds
can exit stage right because all they do
is ask
and beg and want and need and i'm like
wow go back to where you came from
and they're always like you're gonna
miss this when we're gone and i'm like
really i'm not i'm okay go
but i love them honestly that's the
truth
you